i've been trying to be very honest
because
my whole life was
shrouded in secrets
[Music]
that was a teaser for gerard
carmichael's brand new hbo special
rathaniel and during it he comes out as
gay after telling the audience a story
about his father cheating and catching
him doing it once that was all out in
the open within the family he says he
felt like a liar himself because of the
secret that he was keeping drawn says in
the special one that i kept from my
father my mother my family my friends
and you
professionally personally and the secret
is that i'm gay
now the audience during the special was
very supportive of gerard's coming out
and gave him a round of applause to
which he replied i rebelled against it
my whole life i thought i'd never ever
come out at many points i thought i'd
rather die and confront the truth of
that to actually say it to people
because i know it changes some people's
perceptions of me i can't control that
no you can't jarrod will be hosting
saturday night live this weekend and we
will be watching
[Music]
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos